so we've just had a question come in via
Twitter from Levi Kay Dean and Levi
writes for me in terms of screenwriting
how do I script a great scene what
elements and/or components are needed so
to speak and then he adds for mark is
there anything you can add in terms of a
director bringing a great scene to life
so Michael we'll start with you okay I I
guess the best thing I can do is I can
give some suggestions on how to improve
a scene that you're working on the first
thing before you even start writing the
words of the scene you want to step back
and as usual my suggest questions in
other words first of all you should have
already asked the questions who is my
hero
what is the hero's wound what are they
afraid of what is their visible goal
that they're going after and where
structurally does the scene occur
because depending on how far along in
that inner journey the character is
that's going to affect how they would
react in the situation after you figured
those things out then the next question
you want to ask is what does my
character want in this scene and does
that desire is that desire going tor do
they think it's going to move them
closer to their goal or at least
overcome an obstacle to achieving their
goal if the answer to that question is
no then the scene should be jettisoned
it's not serving the story because every
scene has to move the character closer
to their visible goal or force them to
face an obstacle or anticipate an
obstacle that they didn't know they were
going to previously so let's say the
answer is yes though you do know that
this is going to contribute to the goal
and you figure out what do they want to
accomplish within the scene what do they
where do they want to be or what do they
want to have happen to the end of the
scene then what are they going to do to
try and do that that will constitute the
action of the scene the dialogue you
just set aside until all these other
things are figured out because the
dialogue is only really two
vo in some way how they're feeling about
the situation or its dialogue where
they're trying to persuade somebody to
do something or get above somebody else
take control of a situation and so on
but first you want to see what does the
character want in the scene and then
what is the obstacle they must face in
the scene to achieving that because the
motion of a movie and the emotion of any
scene is primarily going to grow out of
the conflict if it's not the conflict
being faced right then it's the conflict
that they are anticipating or
occasionally that the audience is
anticipating and the thriller we may
know that the killers in the next room
and all the hero wants to do is get to
the kitchen to make a sandwich but it's
still it's still about what do they want
and what are we anticipating there's
going to get in their way and then when
it comes to dialogue especially if you
struggle with dialogue get get something
down you should get anything down to
begin with just so you've got a scene to
work with rather than a blank page but
if you don't know what the dialogue
should be write dialogue where the
character is just saying how they feel
and what they want it's what's known as
on-the-nose dialogue it's terrible
dialogue but at least now you've got a
scene
you've got action you've got character
you got dialogue and now you can ask the
last question that would be my
suggestion and that is okay now I know
what they want they're going through
this action how can I make it more
difficult for them first of all but also
instead of having them announce their
feelings or desires can they do it
without saying anything or if they in a
conversation how can they hide their
true desires or feelings and cover it up
with more surface superficial sub
textual language and that's sort of what
you're going for and those are sort of
the beats of going through it then it's
a matter of just going through that
process again and again and again with
each successive draft but that'll
that'll get you to something if you're
looking at a blank page to begin with so
it's good Michael oh thank you
you're very welcome I'm gonna write that
down
you